bonjour monsieur
en tout cas c'est là que je m'apprêtais
à me faire attraper voudriez vous la
réparer je te faire ça pour la fin de la
semaine mon petit parce que j'ai
beaucoup de travail tant parce que je
vais faire ça chez à
bon écoute pour éviter un drame je te le
fais pour ce soir après la classe ça va
bon alors ce soir on va monsieur brochet
vous êtes coiffeur mais vous avez
adjoint à votre travail
la chirurgie esthétique pour couper
pourquoi tout d'abord parce que mon père
était peut-être posticheurs et alors il
a eu des perruques de poupées à faire
avec les cheveux des clientes en leur
petite fille et de là à mettre des
caoutchoucs à ses poupées
il n'y a eu qu'un pas mon père l'a fait
et là moi ensuite j'ai continué à
médical chou aux baigneurs ou baigneurs
et des caoutchoucs je suis passé aux
pièces de rechange les bras les jambes
les têtes et les perruques eux aussi
pour tous ces enfants
en somme vous êtes un véritable
chirurgien on pourrait vous appeler
docteur police et grâce à vous proposer
dans les groupes et retrouvent leur jeu
et la petite fille leur sort est
également oui monsieur pas chez est le
meilleur auxiliaire du père noël
l'art de réparer les poupées
de fixer les bras à un élastique au
moyen d'un crochet
mais là
d'examiner la tête à l'aide d'un miroir
et l'afrique c'est ensuite avec une
fourchette d'examiner les yeux de les
extraire
vous de leur place et je sois les yeux
riboul en fixe moins dépendants
même la pose de la tête avec des
instruments spécialement conçu par
l'artisan est fabriqué de ses mains
les instruments peuvent rappeler ceux du
dentiste et du serrurier prodige du
chirurgien
il connaît par coeur l'anatomie de ses
poupées et d'un coup d'oeil il sera
quelle voie il faut adapter sur tel ou
tel de s'équiper
mais il n'ya pas que cela monsieur pas
cher et par également lé nounours et il
a tout un assortiment dieu comme il
possède les perruques de toutes sortes
les blondes au noir l'autre à l'aide de
belles anglaises
les prises et
d'autres encore pour les poupées
étrangères
ou pour les anciennes
c'est ainsi que sa petite clients tout
prix ce que le matin pour revenir le
soir chercher sa coupe et remise à neuf
dans la journée